عندما أكون بعقل كولومبيا
حدود تي أو كوكوتا
فنزويلا هناك من نهر السين
والأرض الصفراء
ولكن مجرد محبط لأنني
لا يدرسوا من أجل هذا يقومون بعمل مساحات
كما يميز الاستمتاع بالماء
مجرد جاذبية أخرى
استيقظ العمل على هذا الصقيع فرييتس
إطار عمل نتبووك في هذا النوع من
الجينات وتنفيذ كولومبيا بدون
نزل الغليان وبناء السلس في بلدي
الإضافات للرجل ثابتة لأن
عليك أن تدرك أنك
للعمل
خمس سنوات من عمري
الدراسة ولكن مرت خمس سنوات منذ أن كنت
أشعر في هذه اللحظة أنهم كانوا كذلك
ضائع
لأنني لا أستطيع ممارسة ذلك إذا كان
الحكومة لها دور كبير في هذا
الحالي ليس جيدًا ولكنه خطأ
لديه السابق
نموذجي
هل تعتقد أنها ستفهم
سبب قيامك بذلك أمي هو سبب واحد
أمي السوبر أمي هي كل شيء وأنا أعلم
في ذلك اليوم الذي اكتشفوا فيه
أي شيء ثم نعم سوف
يؤلم لأنه نعم ولكنه لن يلدغني
أو أحد الأصدقاء مع النجوم أنا واحد
امرأة لم أتخيلها من قبل للوصول إلى هذا
أقصى الحدود
يوم تجربة ميشيل وأنا
ويكفي أن أعطيه وجبة الإفطار فقط
في بعض الأحيان غداء فقط في بعض الأحيان
اذهب إلى الفراش دون تناول الطعام
وأنا أذهب إلى المدرسة جيدًا حتى
غير ممكن
أخيرًا اليوم الذي تبكي فيه تصلي
في حال ركعت في الليل لأسأله
يا الله حتى أنني ذهبت إلى الكنيسة لأسأله
اغفر لله لأنني أفكر في
وجوه أطفالي
في والدي
ليس من السهل صديق
ومن ثم لديه كوكوتا كولومبيا